[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLLIN FRIERSON:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Collin
Frierson, and today we're
going to be talking
about G Suite Security.
We're going to look at
MDM, Enterprise Security
and Protection and more.
You can ask questions
any time on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
With that, let's get started.
One of the things
we know is it's
becoming increasingly difficult
for IT to manage and protect
assets at scale.
The average IT
organization has thousands
of services they're
trying to manage,
both on prem and in Cloud.
And a high percentage
of data breaches
are caused by employees, due
to a lack of internal controls.
Meaning it's very
difficult to govern
when employees
have access to data
and when they don't, and
where that data goes.
We're also seeing
that patchwork systems
makes the system as a
whole much more vulnerable.
Meaning you're going to
have varying operating
systems on prem, varying
patch levels on those systems.
And those varying patch levels
can be exploited by documents,
by malicious code that are
often delivered via email.
And the costs of these
breaches is going up.
The number of breaches we've
seen is actually increasing.
And data breaches
can be catastrophic.
We understand this
really well at Google,
and we've been
designing our products
to try to address
these concerns.
Some of the things
we've noticed--
90% plus of phishing
attacks start with email.
Similarly with malware, we
see that 66% or maybe even
a little more of
malware is actually
delivered via email or
an attachment via email.
So it's really important we
defend that from the beginning.
And again, a very high
percentage of reported breaches
are caused by either employees
not understanding where
the proper boundaries
are, being extorted,
or by an external threat.
And data exfiltration
is expensive.
We're seeing a super high
increase in the losses
from ransomware over the
last couple of years.
So at Google, we really believe
that being in in a cloud native
can really help you
defend against these types
of modern threats.
There's some
amazing capabilities
that work across the platform,
whether you're in the Google
Drive ecosystem directly
or in Gmail or using
Chrome Enterprise.
Our robust global
infrastructure is designed
to always be up-to-date.
So no one is ever running
an old version of Gmail.
We deploy security patches to
Chrome on a very regular basis.
And the infrastructure is
global so that we minimize
the amount of time your
traffic is actually on the web,
and we bring it into
Google as fast as possible.
So as we're building
products inside of G Suite,
we think about it in a
couple of different buckets--
proactive, intelligent,
compliant, and simple.
So what I'm going to
do today is take you
through each of these areas
of work inside of G Suite.
And then please feel
free to ask questions,
and we can dive into
any area that we
need to do a little bit more.
Proactive, I think, is one
of the most important ones.
Again, we see a ton of
spam and phishing campaigns
that come directly
in from email.
So being defensive at
email is really important.
And Gmail is very effective
at stopping spam and malware.
We have three 9s here, which
is really, really impressive,
and this is hard to do.
The 99.9%, the way we're
able to achieve that,
is actually through
Machine Learning.
I'm going to talk a little
bit more about this in a bit,
but this is how we're able to
classify spam and malware not
just based on signature
or by sender reputation.
We have a lot of signals
that we're able to use.
And we also classify
it in multiple points
during message delivery.
A couple of other
interesting things
we're doing with
Machine Learning.
These are some new stats.
We actually just published
these a couple of weeks ago.
Every minute, we're at 10
million spam messages prevented
from reaching a Gmail inbox.
10 million per minute.
This is a huge number.
And again, this is based
on that Machine Learning
with 99.9% accuracy rates.
Over half a million
pages indexed and scanned
for harmful software.
So this is using the
Google Search engine.
We're actually looking
for malicious sites--
sites that host malware,
links that might
be in your email that would
direct you to a page that
would do something harmful.
7,000 deceitful URLs,
browser extensions
that may carry viruses, unwanted
content, phishing attempts.
Again, we're detecting
7,000 new ones per minute.
And we're also scanning 6,000
instances of software that
could be malicious to Chrome.
These are binaries
that are hosted,
and when you download
them, Chrome would warn you
that this binary may harm
your computer, are you
sure you want to keep it.
And every minute, two phishing
sites and one malware site
are found and
labeled, so they're
added to the Chrome
Safe Browsing database.
This is only possible
with Google Search.
The search engine
and Machine Learning
really make this possible.
And talking more about
the email accuracy,
there's a lot of vendors in this
space that do email detection.
What we really
think sets us apart
is the Machine Learning
that is individualized.
So meaning not only are we
able to detect ransomware,
detect messages
there will morph--
so we'll see these messages try
to beat signature detection,
they'll send millions
of emails and try
to look to see which ones
are the most effective.
But we're also able to
look for things also
that are in the Safe
Browsing database.
So when you attach
a link, Google
will look at where
the link goes.
And then if it's sending
you to a malicious page,
we'll stop you
from getting there.
We'll even strip the link out.
And also, this doesn't just
apply to inbound messages.
This applies to
outbound as well.
So we actually will look
for sensitive information
that you as a G Suite
administrator can configure
with our Data Loss
Prevention engine
and then detect if content that
is leaving the organization
meets compliance rules.
So you can say, look,
if you're sending emails
with a lot of swear words
in them, I could block that.
If you're sending emails
with sensitive information
like credit card numbers,
names, addresses,
once it meets a
certain threshold,
you can warn, block, or
change routing rules.
The email layers of
defenses are really cool,
and there's a lot of them.
So for example, we're doing
a lot of checks pre-delivery.
And this is partly how
we get to that 99.9%.
As a message comes into Gmail,
we look not only for rule-based
matching-- so did it come from a
sender with a poor reputation--
we also are able to even
open any attachments
in a virtual machine
and essentially see
what they did to the machine.
So we'll dump the memory,
we'll look at the disk
and determine really quickly,
usually inside of four minutes,
if that binary is malicious.
This is really how we're
looking for zero days.
And then of course, we'll use
multiple anti-virus engines
to look for known signatures--
if there's a zip file with
contents in it, we'll open it,
we'll extract it all, and
we'll see what's in there.
We also look again
on Message Open.
So we rerun a lot of these
checks on Message Open.
We know that email's
happening in real time.
So even post-delivery,
we can check
to see did the
links in this site
match a new Safe
Browsing data entry.
We can display warning
banners inside of Gmail.
And going even further,
when you open an attachment,
if you're opening it
in the Gmail web UI,
that's actually a sandbox
where we're actually
opening the attachment.
So it's really difficult for
traditional macros or PDF
exploits--
for those to execute inside the
Chrome sandbox inside of Gmail.
Again, looking at Safe
Browsing links on link clicks--
so before you click
on anything, we're
going to check for the
Safe Browsing database,
about where you're
about to be headed.
We're also sending
things like Reply.
So if someone is
impersonating your domain--
so they've spun up a domain
that's very similar to yours,
they have a character
or two that's different,
and they're asking
for information--
Google will automatically
warn the user that hey,
you're about to send
information that's
sensitive outside the domain.
Are you sure you
want to do that?
Again, also doing data
loss prevention checks
when you're doing an OAuth
grant-- so if someone's
trying to ask you to click
on a link that authorizes
a third-party application to
your G Suite applications,
we can actually look at DLP
before we send any information
to that third party.
Finally, some of the best
ones are password verification
and password reset.
So we'll do 2-step verification
when we see suspicious login
attempts.
And we can also challenge
when someone's sending you
password reset emails, we'll
make sure those are really
coming from secure sources.
I think it's also
important to acknowledge
that we can interlock a
lot of these protections
with Chrome OS.
Chrome OS is one of the
most secure computing
platforms on the market today.
And we're not only combining
all of those capabilities
that we just talked
about, but we're
combining it with a secure
foundation for the client.
Meaning the device,
the firmware,
the OS are all designed
with security in mind.
So a couple of examples here.
The first one is
every Chromebook
on the market is fully
encrypted, that's by design.
There isn't a Chromebook on
the market today you can find
that isn't it fully encrypted.
And actually, we're
encrypting the user space.
The OS itself is
actually open source,
so there's no need
to encrypt that.
The firmware is also
designed to have secure boot,
meaning every time
Chrome OS boots,
we actually check to make sure
the OS is intact with firmware.
And if something's
wrong, you'll rarely
see that screen that says,
hey, something's wrong.
You need to insert a USB drive
and reimage your Chromebook.
And again, the OS platform
is managed by Google.
So we're delivering security
updates every six weeks.
Or if you want to opt into
the beta or dev channels,
you can get updates even faster.
But again, you won't
find Chromebooks
that are running really
old versions of Chrome.
We automatically
push these updates.
And we can really stay ahead
of the curve with patching.
All right, with that, let's
talk about intelligence.
So today we actually have
three billion devices
that are checked with
Safe Browsing technology.
And we're, again, scanning
the entire internet
for harmful software
and for malicious sites.
And we want to make all
of this data available.
So one of the tools we
just launched in G Suite
is called Security Center.
Security Center is a
place where administrators
can go to look for
data on everything that
would be relevant to someone
who's a security professional.
t how many phishing emails
am I getting in my domain?
Is it trending up
or trending down?
How many of them are
blocked, how many of them
are blocked retroactively?
How many links am I getting
that contain malware?
How many attachments
contain malware?
And then even data on how
the users are behaving.
How many OAuth links
is a user creating?
What applications
have they authorized
to see data inside their domain?
You can retroactively
go back and revoke.
Finally, in Security
Center, I think
one of the coolest features
is a security assistant
that we have.
It actually provides
recommendations
and best practices for
security in the domain.
And you can see
recommendations like, hey,
if you have your
super admins and they
don't have two-factor
authentication turned on,
you should turn that on.
And you can accept
those recommendations,
or you can say I
accept the risk.
It's live, so it will interact
with you as you go through it.
Really important tool, I
think, to take a look at.
The second one is
Data Loss Prevention.
This tool has been around
in Gmail for a while.
We launched it in
Drive late last year.
So DLP and Drive
will actually let
you look for sensitive
content across
your entire organization.
Meaning when you're looking for
things like names, credit card
numbers--
sensitive data that would likely
be the source of a breach,
you can apply rules
programmatically to that data.
What that means is
you can allow users
to share, so long as
the content isn't filled
with names or credit card
numbers or social security
numbers.
We can hold all that on
Google Platform, by the way.
We have lots of
compliance certifications
showing that we can do that.
But you want to make sure
that your users are still
behaving in a way that's
governed by the security
policy.
This is actually a tool that
was built by Google for itself.
We actually built this as part
of a log sanitization engine.
So it's trained with Machine
Learning, it runs at scale
and operates, actually,
in a very similar way
that our Gmail scanning works.
Every time someone makes
an edit, DLP reruns,
re-evaluate the rules.
So it works on live
documents, and of course, it
works even with
non-Google native objects,
like Word documents, PDFs,
images, things like that.
So with that, let's talk
briefly about compliance.
So at Google, we have a
pretty simple philosophy
when it comes to compliance.
And that is we should
find the strongest
technical certifications
and attestations we
can find globally and
adhere to those standards.
So this has been a huge
body of work for Google.
And we've been looking at
things like the ISO series.
27001 is your standard
Cloud security attestation.
27017 is the list of all
those technical controls.
And ISO 27018 is actually
the Cloud privacy standard,
so it makes sure that the data
that you put inside of G Suite
is private from both a
multi-tendency perspective,
it's private from the host,
which would be Google,
and private from any
third-parties Google
does business with.
So it's a really
strong standard,
I'm really happy we got
that a couple of years ago.
We also offer SOC reports.
So if you need an SSAE
report or a Type 2 report,
we can definitely provide that.
And G Suite is FedRAMP
certified at the moderate level.
So this has also been
around for a while.
But again, it attests to
the strength of the controls
that we have in place.
We're also gearing towards
regulatory compliance,
so things like the US
health care with HIPAA.
So we want to make
sure that if you're
storing health-related
information in G Suite,
we can protect that
data adequately.
Also similarly with
GDPR in the EU.
So we want to make sure that
even the data in G Suite
is held to the highest
privacy standards,
and the EU is really
leading on this.
It's worth mentioning, we offer
this to all of our customers.
We don't differentiate
between the editions.
So regardless of what G
Suite edition you're in,
we're going to offer these to
you no matter where you are.
A couple other
commitments-- there's
never any ads in G Suite.
Google does not
collect your data.
We don't scan it
for advertising.
We don't create archetypes.
We don't do any of
that in G Suite.
You don't have to
believe me on this.
It's in our terms of
service for G Suite.
So you can look at the contract.
It's very, very clear.
You own the data.
This is also in the contract.
Google commits that we have
no intellectual property
rights on any of the
data you put in G Suite.
It's 100% yours, and you're also
responsible for the content.
And your apps are
always available.
We offer a really high SLA.
We also have public
dashboarding to show
the status of our applications.
This SLA includes no
time for maintenance,
so we're always going
to be at three 9s.
We do maintenance all the time,
we do patching all the time.
So we're always going to
be on the latest version,
and we're never going
to take you down
for a maintenance window at
some horrible time in the night.
G Suite is global.
It's always daytime
and working somewhere.
We also really
commit to control.
This is really important.
This to me means two things.
One thing is you can
always take your data out
of Google if you need to.
We don't want you to feel
like you're trapped here.
So if you've been using
Google Docs or Google Slides,
you can always export
that in industry formats
or open formats.
And you can also
delete your data.
So if you tell
Google, hey, I want
to delete all of
this data, we're
contractually committed
to deleting that for you
and processing that command.
And again, we have these
commitments in contract.
You can read more about
them in the terms of service
or in the data
processing amendment.
Last one is simple.
All these security
controls are great.
The philosophy here is
if they're not simple
and it's not very easy
for users to use it,
typically that's how
work-arounds get created
and problems occur.
So the first one is around
the administration side.
The administrator tools that
are in G Suite's central admin
panel are really easy to
use and straightforward.
I use the search panel
a lot, the search panel
is really helpful.
And we even support
natural language query
in the search bar.
So if you type
password resets, we'll
understand what that
means, and we'll
direct you to the right place.
We also include tools in
here for Chrome management.
So if you need to
administer Chrome devices,
whether those are signed-in
Chrome devices or Chrome OS
devices, we can
manage this from here.
We include our mobile
device management in here,
so you can manage iOS
and Android devices.
And we also support
Information Rights Management
through this console.
So you can determine
rules for when content
has a certain requirement,
is that content
allowed to be taken
offline, taken out
of the domain, et cetera.
Really powerful.
There's also controls
for team drives in here.
One of the new things
we launched recently
is called Protected
Team Drives, which
will let you actually define
rules about content in a drive
so that content no matter
what can't be taken offline,
can't be taken
out of the domain.
You can even restrict
copy and print.
It's really powerful.
Our Mobile Device Management
and Cloud Identity
is also becoming really popular.
So we have a ton of devices
now that are under management.
And we've actually
recently simplified
how much weight we
have on the device,
in order to put Mobile
Device Management on there.
So we're calling this
MDM light because we
don't need an agent anymore to
enforce basic policies, things
like encryption and pass codes.
And we also still
support, of course,
you can push a full agent
and have even more control.
This is actually on by
default now for new domains,
which is really exciting.
We definitely want to make sure
administrators have control
when users are accessing their
data from a mobile device,
whether it's Android or iOS.
Finally, I want to spend
a little bit of time
on security keys because this
has been key to even Google's
corporate strategy.
We, of course, eat
our own dog food.
So we use G Suite tools
and Gmail services, just
like all of our customers.
And security keys are
paramount to our strategy
for preventing phishing
attacks and preventing
account hijacking.
Remember, one of the
stats I quoted earlier
was over 70% of phishing
campaigns start with an email.
Security keys are another
layer of defense for us there.
So suppose a phishing
email gets through,
an employee clicks on the link.
The bar we set with
security keys was we
want to build a
credential that's
so strong that it's nearly
impossible for a bad actor
to steal it.
Security keys are how Google
has accomplished that.
Since we deployed
security keys, we've
had no reported or detected
G Suite account hijackings
post-deployment.
So that means an employee
who has a security key--
you know, there have
been lots of attempts
to steal their credential.
None has been successful
that we've detected
or have been reported.
So security keys
work by actually
doing something
very different than
traditional authentication.
Traditional
authentication requires
you to demonstrate to
the server that you
are who you say you are.
What's fundamentally
different about security keys
is security keys require
that the server demonstrate
to the client that
it's trustworthy.
So now we're doing
bidirectional authentication.
So when you're authenticating
with a security key,
the server actually
demonstrates to the client
that it really is
who it says it is.
You're really in a TLS
connection with the server,
there's not a man in the middle.
There's not a bad
actor phishing page.
And that credential
that you send
can't be replayed or reused.
We have a great
white paper on this.
If you want to know more, I can
tell you about our experience
with security keys, which
is a public white paper.
Or you can learn more about
U2F from the FIDO alliance.
So all that being
said, we really
believe that our strength
is better together.
Combining the strength of G
Suite with Chrome and Android
and even GCP is really going
to help you build a security
framework that is extended
beyond the traditional
perimeter.
As employees become more
mobile, as identities really
start to span outside of
the traditional premiere,
we think we're building the
most powerfully secure Cloud
platform you can
adopt out there.
Tying it all together, we
want default-on mobile device
management.
So we want to be
able to say users
who are signing in and accessing
Google data from mobile device
managed services are going
to be following basic rules,
like is my device
encrypted, do I
have a passcode on my lock
screen, things like that.
Advanced anti-phishing
capabilities, so again, this
is when we're using Chrome,
any link we click on,
any email that we
get, any attachment
that's delivered to our
mailbox is going to be scanned.
We're going to be
looking for bad behavior
and blocking that by
the end user by default.
Deploying security keys
to the organization.
So we're doing the
strongest 2FA possible.
And we're making sure that
users who are coming in really
are who they say
they are, and they're
authenticating to
the real servers
and not to hijacked
or malicious places.
Using the Security Console in
G Suite and DLP to make sure
the rules of the
organization are followed,
and content is where
it belongs and not
being shared either
accidentally or maliciously.
And then finally, using
a tool like Google Vault
to assure legal compliance
with all of the data
that you're putting
in G Suite, so you
can support things
like eDiscovery.
With that, I definitely
want to thank everyone.
Stay tuned for live Q&A. And
we will be back in less than a
minute.
All right, we're
back with questions.
So a couple of questions
from the audience.
Do I need a separate
security key
for each account I log into?
This is a great question.
Security keys, the relationship
between keys and accounts
is actually many to many.
So for any particular
Google account,
you can actually register a very
large number of security keys
with that account, so you
don't have to have just one,
in case you lose it.
And that key can actually be
used to unlock many accounts.
So in my case, my
one security key
will unlock my corporate
account, my personal Gmail.com
account as well as a bunch
of other demo accounts.
And it even works for other
third party sites, sites
like GitHub, Facebook, Dropbox.
They all support
security keys natively.
So you don't need to get a
separate key for each service.
And you can have multiple
keys for your services,
so you don't have to worry
about losing your one key.
Does Google encrypt
data at rest?
Yes, we do.
Google actually
encrypts everything
by default with no action
required by the administrator.
We have a great white
paper on this that talks
about how we encrypt data.
So if you want to learn
more, search for G Suite data
encryption, and we'll tell
you how we encrypt data
both in transit and at rest.
The great thing is you
can't turn this off.
So it's always going to be on,
and G Suite is really fast.
So it's a great, great
feature of the platform.
How does Google vault and DLP
work with the new Gmail UI
confidential mode?
Vault and DLP
functionality don't change.
So DLP scans run
on send or receive.
So DLP runs any time you're
sending or receiving a message.
So even if you're in
Confidential mode,
we will still run DLP checks.
And Google vaults
works the same way.
We will still vault
and archive messages
regardless of whether
using confidential or not.
Are DLP and Security Center
are available for all G
Suite for business
or only Enterprise?
This is a good question.
We're always moving
the addition things.
I think Security Center and
DLP are in Enterprise for sure.
I'm going to have to
check on whether they're
in the business SKU or not.
I don't remember.
I think some customers that
were grandfathered on business
before we launched Enterprise
probably have access
to some of these features.
I'm not an expert on SKUs.
I apologize.
Does Drive DLP
scan current files
or only ones that
have subsequently
been uploaded or created?
Drive DLP scans everything.
So when you first
launch, a Drive DLP rule
will actually scan everything
in the organization.
So if you set a policy--
if it's your first
policy, you'll
see a pop-up that
says it may take up
to 24 hours for this
rule to take effect.
But that's because
we're scanning
all of the shares
inside the organization.
So we're looking across
any existing shares.
And again, once the
rule is enacted,
we're looking on every edit.
So if I have a bunch of
confidential information
and I'm sharing a
document with someone
and I paste all that
information into the document,
DLP will run as part
of that and then
subsequently change my sharing
settings as a result of that.
So even if I'm in a live
document, and I'm typing.
As soon as the keystrokes I type
create a social security number
or whatever the DLP
rule will detect,
it will block and change
that sharing setting.
So it works on everything.
All right, is that all
the questions we have?
Yeah, OK.
Thanks so much for watching.
Tune in next Tuesday for
another edition of Cloud OnAir.
[MUSIC PLAYING]